Last week, Donald Trump claimed he would be
throwing out a first pitch at Yankee Stadium
on August 15th.
Trump then tweeted, canceling it, saying,
quote, Because of my strong focus on the China
virus, including scheduled meetings on capital,
the vaccines, our economy and much else, I
won't be able to be in New York to throw out
the opening pitch for the Yankees on August
15th.
We will make it later in the season.
And I speculated Trump's worried he'll look
stupid because he looked really dumb throwing
a baseball around last week.
He doesn't want to be ridiculed for a bad
first pitch or Trump doesn't want to get booed
like he's been booed at other stadiums, which
was just wrong of me to say, because there's
no crowds right now at baseball games or Trump
doesn't want to be rebuked by all of the players
because overwhelmingly Major League Baseball
players have been kneeling during the national
anthem.
If Trump's there while that's going on, that's
not going to look particularly good for Trump.
I was overanalyzing.
The truth is, there was no first pitch.
There was no first pitch to cancel.
Trump made it all up.
When Trump announced this, his own staff knew
there was no such thing on his schedule.
The Yankees knew there was no such thing on
their schedule.
What happened was that Trump was so jealous
of Anthony Foushee that he told his staff,
call it my friend at the Yankees and tell
them tell him I want to throw out a first
pitch.
There was no actual date.
Behind the scenes, chaos ensued and ultimately,
Trump ended up canceling an event that never
even existed with the tweet that I showed
you earlier.
And it all goes back to Trump's uncontrollable
jealousy.
It's really envy of Dr. Foushee.
When Trump said he was invited to throw out
the first pitch, it was an hour before Dr.
Foushee actually threw out the first pitch.
Fragile Trump was triggered and was just lying.
That's it.
That's the explanation.
Should this surprise us?
No, the lying certainly should not.
Trump likes to lie regularly about easily
disproven things.
You know, the size of his crowd corona virus
testing.
He lies all the time about everything.
The really dangerous part.
Is the weaponized jealousy of Dr. Foushee
Fouche, she's a doctor and Trump isn't.
And yet Trump is in some kind of bizarre competition
with Foushee, as if they have equally valid
opinions on medical issues, which they don't.
I should.
I can't believe I have to clarify that, but
they don't.
Trump is petty to the point of being delusional,
and that has been normalized over the last
three years.
Remember when Trump tweeted, you know, Time
magazine was something like Time magazine
called me and said I was probably going to
be Man of the Year, Person of the year, whatever
last year.
But I would have to agree to do like an interview
in a major photo shoot.
And I'm just too busy.
So I passed completely made up.
I mean, just fabricated out of thin air.
Then Trump ended up being mad that Gretta
Toon Berg ended up being Time's Person of
the Year.
It's all insane.
It is weaponized envy.
It is delusional ignorance.
It is a global laughingstock.
And we I'm not even going to say it.
You know what we have to do?
We do it in three months and then we move
on and we start returning to normality, normalcy,
normality.
I prefer to say normality, despite it maybe
not being a word.
So this is unbelievable or maybe too believable.
It turns out that Donald Trump was never invited
to throw out the first pitch at Yankee Stadium,
which he claims to have canceled.
It appears he was simply jealous that Dr.
Anthony Foushee was invited to throw out the
first pitch at Yankee Stadium opener last
week.
And Trump first said, I will be invited and
I will be doing it soon.
Then later, he said he was going to be too
busy.
This is actually the clearest explanation.
This is not the most important news story,
but it puts together a bunch of really important
things, one of which is Donald Trump's jealous
disdain for Dr. Anthony Foushee, which led
to Trump tweeting nonsense about Foushee in
the middle of the night last night.
Trump completely lacking focus on anything
important during a pandemic.
While he's golfing, tweeting and being jealous
of Anthony Foushee and thinking about first
pitches.
But let's get caught up first.
So we all know what we're talking about.